Bluetooth is an
amazing technology
that allows us to wirelessly
communicate with devices.
Bluetooth has been
around for a long time.
But since the introduction
of Bluetooth low energy,
we've seen a massive rise in
the number of Bluetooth devices
around us, everything
from headphones
to heart rate monitors.
BLE is cheap and consumes
very little power,
which makes it great
for mobile devices.
Soon, everything from parking
meters to vending machines
will have a BLE chip inside.
But there is one common problem.
To interact with any
of these devices,
users need to install a native
app-- an app for the San
Francisco parking meter, an
app for the Palo Alto parking
meter, an app for the
Mountain View parking meter.
Each app adds massive
amounts of friction
for users that just
want to interact
with the device
in front of them.
Soon, the number of
apps in our cellphones
will become unmanageable.
More importantly, why should
you download an app for things
that you're going to
use once or twice?
Wouldn't it be great
if all of these
just worked directly
from a web page?
My name is Giovanni, and I'm
an engineer on the Chrome team.
And I'm here today to talk to
you about Bluetooth on the web
and how the Web Bluetooth
API that we're implementing
in Chrome, combined
with the Physical Web,
will change the way you interact
with the devices around you.
Let's take a step
back for a moment
and talk about the Physical Web.
The Physical Web is an early
stage experimental project
that allows users to
discover devices around them.
Using BLE, objects
can work as a URL
that the Physical Web picks
up and presents to the user.
For example, a movie poster can
broadcast a link to the movie
trailer, or a parking meter can
broadcast a link to a website
where you can pay for parking.
In a way, the
Physical Web concept
is similar to that of QR
codes, but the Physical Web
offers some key advantages.
First, the Physical
Web will eventually
be part of your smartphone,
so there is no need for users
to download an app.
Furthermore, the Physical
Web is more convenient.
Users shouldn't need to climb
on a ladder to snap a QR
code on their small detector.
With the Physical
Web, you can similarly
discover devices and
objects around you.
But the question remains,
how do you connect with them?
This is where Web
Bluetooth comes in.
Web Bluetooth will allow
users to seamlessly connect
to the devices around
them without the need
to start an app and will
enable developers to build
cross-platform web apps.
For example, users
would be able to walk up
to any parking meter in any city
and then use the Physical Web
to navigate to the
corresponding web app.
Once a user pays for
parking, the websites
can then notify the parking
meter directly, using BLE.
The same concept can be
applied to many devices
where power consumption
is an issue and internet
connectivity is not viable.
We are currently
working on the API
to make all this
available to developers.
But before we show you how the
current proposed API works,
let's review some BLE concepts.
A characteristic contains
a value and descriptors
that describe that value.
You can think of
a characteristic
as a type analogous to a class.
Services, a service is just a
collection of characteristics.
For example, a
heart rate monitor
has a heart rate service.
The heart rate service
contains a characteristic,
called heart rate
measurement, which
calls a value of the
user's heart rate.
A website could then
connect to the device
to read and write
to characteristics
or subscribe notifications
from characteristics.
It's pretty simple.
The developer will request
access to a device filter
by service.
In this case, heart rate.
The system will
then ask the user
to confirm that
they want the web
app to pair with the device.
Once the user has
granted access,
the developer will then be
able to get direct access
to the service on the device,
which means that now you
can get access to the services
characteristics, which
in this case, will let you read
the heart rate from the device.
And it's a very similar
process for writing data
to a Bluetooth device.
You get access to the
device, to the service
and the characteristic, and
then you called writeValue.
It's really that simple.
And a slight more
enhanced use case
is the ability to be notified
when data on a characteristic
changes.
For example, the heart rate
measurement characteristic
allows you to subscribe
to notifications.
Now, every time the heart rate
changes, the website updates
the value shown to the user.
Now that you've seen
what the API looks like,
you probably want to
get your hands on it.
While we work on
finishing up the API
and integrating
it into Chrome, we
have built a Chrome
apps polyfill
that you can use
to try out the API.
You can embed the
polyfill in a Chrome app
and use it in a Chromebook
to scan for devices,
connect to them, read and
write characteristics,
and subscribe to
notifications in the same way
you would using the
Web Bluetooth API.
Don't have a BLE
peripheral available?
Fret not.
We have built an
Android app that
lets you simulate a BLE
peripheral with services
and characteristics that
you can read, write, or get
notifications from.
By using both, we are sure
you will be able to try out
the Web Bluetooth API.
Today, we have given you
a quick glimpse into what
we are enabling on the web.
You can find out more about how
to play with it at this URL.
We look forward to getting
your feedback on the API
specification in the W3C group
and learning about your use
cases.
Thanks, for watching.
And remember, stay connected.
[MUSIC PLAYING]